[Musique]
sera question j'aurais souhaité que le
premier ministre ou le milieu des autres
maires de répondre parce que pour nous
le sujet qui haridwar le travail très
important et la crise aux antilles
plusieurs raisons à une réponse du
gouvernement qui est tardive et il faut
une mobilisation forte pour régler ce
problème outre un marin et la réponse
apportée par le ministre sur place être
le sujet
de l'autonomie et est surprenante et
inquiétante à une semaine du référendum
sur la nouvelle galerie où il ya cette
menace d'indépendance donc les mots ont
un sens cela ils ont certaines
ambiguïtés ou tôt en termes autonomie
c'est pour ça que j'ai invité le
gouvernement doit se saisir des termes
de différenciation permettre du
développement dans les territoires
ultramarins avec leur potentiel
considérable pour la nation française
puis là demain la veille de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne on sait même que nos
partenaires européens sont très
attentifs à ce qui se passe dans les
territoires ultramarins et donc ça doit
être à l'agenda aussi une présidence
française de l'union européenne encore
vraiment aujourd'hui il faut une
mobilisation politique et sur le sujet
[Musique]